Oh
[Music]
brought to you by the new Samsung
Chromebook plus the first Chromebook
made for Google Play what's going on
guys
San Diego comic-con 2017 we are awash in
Deadpool's and Harley Quinn's and all
sorts of fun stuff I'm sitting here with
two of my favorite people
Roth Cornett and Andy signor Howrah live
yes we are live can you believe it and
I'm also holding in my hand an official
Kingsman fidgets be careful it's a bomb
Taron Egerton told us that OMG
we are they're blowing up right here at
Comic Con they had they dropped new
footage this morning new trailer lots of
special stuff and you guys had the
opportunity to sit down with like the
whole cast of the movie Bridges Oscar
winner
really live yes unbelievable I'm that
film guy what was it like being that
close to Channing Tatum I mean Roth he
was awesome he was he was right they
were all really great they were in good
moods I think they're really excited
about the film but I have to say for
myself
it is indeed Jeff Bridges at this point
he's reached legend status yes yes
Channing remembered your name that's
always a time telling I'm staying out of
school cuz that was off the cameras but
I'm giving him credit because you know
when an actor's legit is when they when
you introduce yourself they've met a
million people but then as you same he's
like by Roth it was like I was like that
guy's a pro I like them that's the tatum
yeah that's what that's legend status
you go from heartbreaker to instead they
were all legends and pow we have clips
yeah we do let's throw to an interview
with the entire cast and eat Roth and
the cast of the Kingsmen the Golden
Circle San Diego comic-con we saw the
footage at the panel but I got to seal
it with extra this looks fantastic
energy Matthew Vaughn clearly is
bringing it back again for the sequel
it's so frenetic and fun and creative
balls-to-the-wall you guys must be so
excited but I heard you chanting uh you
were saying in the beginning that you
were a fan of the first one like me what
was it about this franchise and why are
you so excited about the sequel it just
felt so fresh I mean Matthew's in every
single one of his movies he put such
like attention to detail and casting and
I think it was genius to find Taran and
Taran just like is eggsy now I think and
whether you like it or not you're gonna
be that's that's how we met you and how
this was a fan like a fan fan of the
first movie and it was so I think at a
time where all those big sort of pop
movies started to kind of feel the same
this just came out and was straight-up
punk rock didn't give any didn't give no
FS and just did it just did its own
thing I had its own style its own tone
and it was just different and wasn't
afraid of it didn't apologize for it and
I don't know I think it won people over
for it did the rest of the new Jeff and
how did you feel that way - did you like
the original I didn't know what to
expect when I saw the original coming
from the Bond movie though I did hear
that it's kind of like a bomb moving but
maybe better okay let me watch this and
I watched it and I was just well I
didn't I didn't say that someone else
said that let me watch it and I was
pleasantly surprised how how fresh it
was and how exciting it was and I
thought women will actually like this -
I love this movie - and I think you're
right though that people do feel that it
is a harkening back to bond because it
is spies who are having fun being spies
they're embracing at this big villains
and Matthew Vaughn seems to be the
director that every franchise once for
his precision and that ability to do
humor and action what do you guys think
it is about him that makes him so sought
after as a director like an artist of
entertainment he knows how to really
heighten that experience of having fun
in cinema and I think that that's why we
all get so addicted to the experience of
a Matthew
movie in Teheran I'll tell you this is
the first time he's ever done a sequel
and it so he gets to expand on on his
own invention which you can only imagine
what that would mean I guess wonderful
to work with to the environment that he
creates on this set you know that's
something I look for as an actor no you
know what but the director what the
director comes up with you know the the
mood of the director and his is one of
joy and relaxation and everybody is
feeling happy and he's got a certainly
has his vision but he's open to
collaboration wants to know all the
actors ideas as well lot of fun well
this one he steps up in the sequel
because I love this idea of The
Statesman coming I had no spoilers but
the clearly Kingsman need help they have
to figure out in but then we introduced
these statesmen which is such a fun
element obviously introducing Channing
and Jeff what's like what's the
difference here who do you think would
really win The Statesman or the Kingsmen
obviously Kingsman is you know snow no
secrets in the trailer is completely
obliterated so I guess when you've you
know injury during the events of the
movie it's been a probably in slightly
better shape for some for resources full
resources and obviously because the
Statesmen there front is that they have
a liquor business they make whiskey
kentucky bourbon and i think that's
probably a little bit more lucrative
than being Savile Row
Taylor so they have like great you get
to do a lot of tech write your character
how your intercooled stuff we should be
excited for uh yeah I think so I get to
be the female mark Strong and that's
kind of sexy amazing weapons in this
movie too I particularly like the Rope
can you make literally anything into a
weapon
I haven't you catch it everyone always
goes on about Colin and his umbrella
I've got a cool new do you go weapons a
bit yeah the umbrella is quite good
mercy won't let me use it either so yes
a little bit of whatever can you make a
fidget spinner actually be a weapon that
that is an explosive I love it you guys
gave us one you give us toy is it's so
fun I didn't Jeff you're taught a lot of
people look up to you and you're
obviously a your Channing sort of
protege or mentor to him and the
character it seems I'm in real life as
well and all of us unofficially you're
my spirit to wrap this up we are
comic-con you guys are special agents
i'm just yours who would you cosplay as
oh you would see what someone out there
will have one for next year Jeff who
would you cosplay I'm sure there's many
dudes yeah I would be one of those guys
who did it dude you know I guess I dude
maybe so wouldn't get any better than
that would be strange going out as
yourself like with the mosque I might
break out the truck my Trond leotard
[Music]
I would go trying if I could get the
right lighting and everything well thank
you guys so much for coming the film
looks amazing guys you will have to
check this film out when it comes out in
this fall I cannot wait to see it and
thank you guys so much for your time to
enjoy your bow that was cool yeah that
was amazing
I mean Roth I'm impressed you to his
face you let Jeff ridges know that he
was your spirit animal I really wanted a
hug and I I didn't I didn't I didn't go
fully there I didn't fully ask for that
I think he would have done it if I asked
him oh I think you would have too but
yeah we're live now but I was in that
moment did you feel a little bit I felt
like it was doctor strange I was I was
watching it I'm like I called Jeff
Bridges Jeff yeah I was like I'm just
gonna call him Jeff I mean he is flesh
and blood just as you are or is no but
what an honor and I'm so grateful they
came in here amazing how come Colin
Firth didn't want to say anything to you
what did you do to a senator he was
really quiet during the panel as well
he's actually he seemed pretty nervous
to say anything that would be a spoiler
about how he's in fact in the sequel I
think that's what he was afraid of
gotcha
Andy and I made up a song last night
remember is it worth it let me further
it yeah
if anyone out there can finish that
entire song parody put it in the comment
section below that'd be great I still
think he might be a Force Coast you
might yeah he's like maybe he's not
really alive he's there too like who
knows I still maintain that the force of
his pure wit British will stopped the
bullet and that he was just like I
refuse to acknowledge a bullet and
therefore you do not exist that is how
amazingly bird I love him he's mr. Darcy
oh I know the ladies love first okay I
didn't realize this first has a power
over women yeah of course um so you guys
saw I was turned away from the panel
this morning and dragged out by security
but you guys saw a ton of footage like
almost a half hour worth of footage from
the film
let's hear some instant reacts dope
talking cuz we were I'm sorry I I was I
liked it a lot
truth be told they'd let us come and see
a little bit of it earlier just to sort
of get prepared for it and it was pretty
amazing to see it in its context so I've
got to see I got to really see it again
and it was good the second time too was
just an amazing frenetic energy that
he's and the trailer shows a lot of it
too but it was just amazing to be able
to get the energy back of the first one
because I'm a huge fan the first one and
you you know you're always word of the
sequal are they gonna go to bring it and
this I left like wow I want to talk
about this movie I'm not yeah I'm so
gonna be talked about this movie cuz I
really am excited for this trailer as
action-packed
who's the big bad in this movie or who
are they uh really going up against it's
so it's Julianne Moore as the big bad in
this one and it's actually they showed
four clips one was kind of a parody
thing that you guys can watch with
Archer which is really hilarious oh yeah
it's great
Archer Kingsman mashup it's awesome and
then that one's great and then they
showed the opening sequence which is
this amazing set piece and action
sequence you know Matthew Vaughn has
famously avoided sequels and I think
it's because of the pressure of a sequel
if we think of sequels there's a couple
Godfather two that are iconic Lee great
but they are hard to do and he's avoided
it but he did this one and he said it
was very hard to do but he's proud of it
so it comes in with this incredible
kinetic action sequence still really fun
it's spy's having fun loving being spies
then there's a fight sequence that they
showed between Channing and Taryn and
then they show Julianne Moore who is an
amazing big bat in this movie she's a
drug queen pin who's obsessed with the
50s and so I have this whole Enclave in
the middle of the jungle that's like 50s
retro with robots disco BOTS dogs I mean
would you consider a you say a Matthew
Vaughn shied away from sequels but x-men
first class sort of a sequel I mean yeah
reboot yeah yeah technicality yeah so
and was starting his own version of that
I yes yes and he definitely kind of
revitalized the x-men franchise with it
it wasn't a continuation of another yeah
and he didn't do kick-ass to chose not
to so look I hope it has to suffered for
it it was it was good but yeah I think
this is the one that'll make or break
whether this is really the franchise
like successful franchise and III have
to say I remember the first one I
remember really liking the first one
and then when I got to when we got to
see this footage a car came back of like
yeah this is a no-holds-barred like
r-rated just doesn't give an F sort of
really but then not only that but it's
like that his his attention to detail is
so wonderful like the action sequence
they shown the beginnings is like fight
scene in a car chase and it's like that
those can be so poor bad to do or so
like chaotic or you're not sure what's
going on but he keeps it funny he keeps
it surprising you're you bought its CG a
little bit but you you don't care yeah
because it's almost like Chaplin esque
and it's just like you're just like I
love this there are so many nods to the
spy genre and the James Bond
you know franchise of films but it made
it its own that church sequence and the
character with the blades as legs I mean
it definitely had its own tone and
they're not afraid as we're saying
they're not afraid to enjoy themselves I
mean I think that's one of the biggest
things with villains right now we don't
have kind of like the you know odd job
type of villain it's just unafraid to be
big and epic and ridiculous and this
franchise is their franchise yeah jaws
like these amazing Bond villains that
are just larger than life and I think
that this franchise is unafraid to do
that which is so fun I liked Samuel
Jackson everyone give him a bad rap
because of the Lisp and everything but
as the villain we got to see a clip with
her as poppy she brings it to there's a
different energy in it it's a really
sort of funny and disturbing nature does
she have a speech impediment she's very
powerful yeah and she's not afraid to
make her people know it I mean we can't
with no spoilers you know I don't like
spoiling but yeah there's this me we
made heard sort of initiating some
henchmen yeah and he puts them through
the ringer footage I loved Julianne
Moore so I can't think about the
Kingsmen without harkening back to my
trip to England where I guess was basic
favorite clips of you ever thanks Andy
yeah I caused an international incident
and I'm not allowed in the UK ever again
yeah I mean I think brexit was because
of me seeing his genius because they
know what we do what they are in for but
yeah so uh tattoo and we put this too
far at the end of the video
yeah people to appreciate its it's
hilarious yeah they stopped watching
before they got it was a very dry moment
we're like 20 members of the
International Press were standing around
in this tailor shop that made the
fineries for parliament and British
actors and royalty so we were getting an
explanation of how that goes down and I
was like oh you know what I'm just going
to do the stupidest [ __ ] ever right now
do we have the clip we have a little
taste
how could not help himself but add some
Bret brevity levity comic on we are one
of the oldest houses on Savile Row we
were founded back in 18-49 we used to
dress Ian Fleming as well he was a
creator of James Bond
where does Austin Powers get his fancy
clothes the first one come in it's how
you imagine somewhere it would be is it
true that some of the suits here cost as
much as millions are one of the
important bits that they don't mention
to you when they're fitting you but are
the details that they notice about the
way you stand whether you've got a big
paunch if you've been drinking too much
beer are your sizes flexible enough to
fit say a fat bastard good good Austin
Powers to company three nothing he was
in both okay good man yet again I
squandered a great opportunity also I
was pulled aside and politely asked not
Austin Powers references if you're a
lip-reader you can clearly see me saying
no more Austin Powers
I've dealt a serious blow English
British relations because they did not
deserve that but it was reserved very
nice that was the fly in the ointment
that was wonderful and yeah I got to go
to England on there you know what I
think problem how could they not like or
maybe they just hate it
hey they showed up here today so they
bust some loose you know what this is
this is super great so you guys after
seeing all the footage you're encouraged
about kings ii Kingsman the Golden
Circle yeah yes I think that this is the
story that Fox only showed Kings man
which in a way is a pretty bold move on
their part because they do have Deadpool
and they do have new mutants and things
that comic-con would be looking forward
to so I think that that what they're
trying to say the message is like get
excited for Kingsman and I think they
delivered it yeah I mean look as a fan
of all these movies I was a little
bummed we didn't get to see some other
tastes but I agree I think bold move to
focus on this they brought out the big
guns with the cast and thank God it was
good because we did have Miramar not
sing that cuz they were here like I
really was jazzed by this footage and it
made me more excited that they were
hearing that we could talk about it and
share with you and I think now people
are seeing like the clip and the
trailers they're seeing okay Matthew
Vaughn's back I'm a big fan of his he's
a really great director and the fact
that he thinks there's more to this and
now that we can see it that introduction
of Channing Tatum with the king when you
meet them it's like it's theirs I decide
my fan of story you clearly understand
what's good something happens they need
to enlist some help and it's a brilliant
way to sort of up the game as sequels
need to do and I won yeah and I love
Pedro Pascal I'm still heartbroken over
the red Viper of Dorne
the one question I didn't get in was
that I was assuming that he's in the
movie long enough for us to really
really love him and then just die
violently yeah that's all he'll ever do
in anyway from now on it's like what's
his name from King
so I mean Sharpie exactly he's the new
Sean Bean you guys you got me excited
for the movie are you excited for
Kingsman the Golden Circle all cells JT
perfect shot
also what actor or actress is your
spirit animal let us know in the
comments section below
Roth Cornett Andy signor and will be
live again tomorrow at 4 p.m. here in
the main channel for flick babe BAM come
back tomorrow for flick bait and just
watch all of our coverage it's off the
charts and yeah happy comic-con bye bye